tout le monde avait pris l'engagement
avant que on resterait ensemble qu'on
resterait le premier groupe d'opposition
au sénat la majorité a tranché il faut
l'accepter
il ya 34 voix pour les deux candidats et
36 voix pour didier guillaume
voilà en tout cas de voir si on
rassemble suivre ainsi que celle de
laura et c'est le résultat maintenant le
plus important c'est que nous soyons un
groupe uni et que fasse bien sûr à la
droite sénatoriale mais aussi face aux
décisions du gouvernement
il y a un groupe socialiste parce que ce
qui s'est passé dimanche montrent qu'il
ya un espoir le parti sont disait
comment mort qu'on disait agonisant à
montrer dans les élections sénatoriales
c'était bien bien tenu et maintenant
faisons en sorte d'être un groupe uni
qui fasse des propositions et qui soit
capable d'animer la vie sénatoriales
vous avez confiance en didier guillaume
pour défendre la ligne arrêtée ce matin
c'est à dire ne pas se situer dans la
majorité présidentielle on sait qu'ils
avaient eu des propos qui n'allait pas
dans ce sens y ait encore quelques mois
willy disais ouais c'est vrai mais ça a
été voté très largement à la
quasi-unanimité nous ne sommes pas un
majorité présidentielle et didier
guillaume s'est engagé le justement à ne
pas être dans la majorité présidentielle
est en même temps que nous soyons une
force de proposition dans deux contextes
politiques qui est vraiment très lourd